the power structure at the morning show
is shifting with the new voices and
younger generations we have some
fabulous new cast members we have more
incredible story lines we have new
amazing characters okay should we have
the conversation about bradley that i
think we're all thinking is she really
cutting it greta came in and just
swooped just all off of our feet what i
want is to change things here stella
bach is the youngest and only female
news president in the history of uba i
want to build things but i can't build
them but the ground isn't level she's
essentially the new corey ellison
there's no reason why they would get
along and see eye to eye and they
definitely do butt heads her point of
view seems to be you're lucky to have me
clear the wax out of your ears so you
can hear what i'm telling you uba's new
year's eve extravaganza tomorrow night
live i've spent years putting on a suit
pretending to be a fake news anchor so
transitioning over to the morning show
was just an extension
i was asked to submit my audition tape
during my sister's wedding i called mom
i said will you sing with me really
quick we did a little duet together and
that was the weirdest audition tape i've
ever put together in my life the top
trending topic this morning is alex levy
when ty comes into this world he's new
and fresh and he's not involved with the
internal games and mechanics of trying
to get up the ranks of upa hello who are
you and how did you get in here oh
that's ty fitzgerald he's actually on
the show i know who that is i was really
nervous to act opposite jen i really am
so looking forward to working with you
well i'm really excited to be worked
with
worked with yes
she was so friendly and so supportive
that i forgot about all my anxieties
well look who's here julianna margulies
is an incredible addition to the show
there she is here i am she's brilliant
and so talented she was on er and i was
on friends and our stage doors opened up
and we chat with each other who would
have thought 25 years later we'd be
finally on the same set alex if you're
ready my character laura peterson is the
network's golden ticket she can pretty
much do anything she wants what was the
nature of your relationship with mitch
kessler
you never see anything like it someone
coming in so well prepared take after
take after take it's just
quite impressive it was an incredible
experience coming into the show where
everybody on this set is a master of
their craft jumping into this vat of
incredibly talented women it was an
embarrassment of riches i'm so excited
to come to work and to get to do it with
these people who i love it's a total
dream
[Music]